ich habe das teuerste Zugticket der Welt
für 17.000 € gekauft über Nacht von
Venedig bis nach Paris für die pure
Entspannung erwartet uns in der Suite
unter anderem eine Kaviar und obstplatte
ein unfassbar gemütliches Doppelbett und
ein voll ausgestattetes Badezimmer mit
Dusche im Preis enthalten war ein Lunch
und ein Dinner mit jeweils einem
Vier-Gänge-Menü in einem der drei
verschiedenen Restaurant Wagen an Bord
alles frisch und vor Ort vom Chefkoch
zubereitet während der Zugfahrt kann man
also die italienische Landschaft
genießen ein Nickerchen machen
Postkarten an Freunde und Familie
schreiben oder über diesen Knopf immer
wieder Champagner stellen
nach dem Duschen ging es dann satt und
zufrieden ins Bett bis wir am nächsten
Morgen mit einem riesen Frühstück
geweckt wurden und in Paris angekommen
sind der Zug hält was er verspricht aber
egal wie viel Champagner wie gut das
Essen oder wie toll wir geschlafen haben
nichts auf dieser Welt rechtfertigt den
Preis für so eine Zugfahrt man müsste
also völlig verrückt sein so viel Geld
dafür auszugeben aber